avec bien sûr hélène frade bonjour allen
bonjour damien à la une de la presse
notamment ce matin il ya toujours la
campagne pour la présidentielle en
france à 3 mois à peu près du premier
tour et est le déplacement hier à nice
d'emmanuel macron sur le thème de la
sécurité un président en campagne
d'après nice matin le quasi candidat
emmanuel macron a annoncé une hausse
damien de 25% du budget des forces de
sécurité dans un engagement qu une
promesse électorale puisque le texte ne
sera pas voté quoi qu'il en soit avant
la présidentielle la sécurité l'un des
principaux points faibles du quinquennat
sur lequel le président cherche à
muscler son jeu avant le scrutin dixit
le figaro qui voit le président chassé
sur les terres des nationalistes et de
la droite la droite qui semble elle-même
emboîté le pas à une manuelle macron
avec le déplacement hier également de la
candidate lr valérie pécresse à
argenteuil 7 en banlieue parisienne une
ville de le monde rappelle qu'elle est
devenue un symbole des quartiers
populaires depuis que nicolas sarkozy a
promis de débarrasser ses habitants de
la racaille je le cite le monde rapporte
que l'entourage de la candidate assure
lui que cette visite n'être aucunement
une réponse à emmanuel macron mais que
c'est le président qui répondent à
valérie pécresse
bref le débat sur la sécurité à propos
duquel la croix prévient que rien ne
serait pire que de s'arrêter aux
chiffres oseo posture pour sortir des
discours trop simple damien le journal
s'est immergé plusieurs mois dans un
commissariat de roubaix c'est dans le
nord de la france un grand reportage qui
est à retrouver sur le site du journal
est dense où l'hebdomadaire oui un hand
enquête une enquête exclusive de 40
pages qui est passionnante et qui montre
notamment comment fonctionne un
commissariat et pourquoi les effectifs
de police même si on les augmente ça ne
suffit pas le candidat d'extrême droite
eric zemmour lui présenter ses voeux à
la presse un hier à cette occasion le
polémiste à railler ses anciens
confrères un discours presque insultant
mais qui se voulait humoristique selon
le monde qui rapporte qu eric zemmour a
présenté ses ex-confrères comme les
professionnels les plus détestés de
france et oui damian l'ex journaliste a
aussi détaillé quelques pistes de
réforme pour l'école qui l'accusent
d'être un lieu où l'idéologie féministe
lgbt antiracistes et des colonials ouf
en doctrine les enfants le lieu d'une
bataille culturelle où il faudrait
revenir entre autres au port de la
blouse symbole d'égalité selon lui vu
par l'orient-le jour eric zemmour c'est
le prétendant à l'elysée le plus
emblématique d'un scrutin marqué par le
thème du malaise identitaire d'une
france morcelée blessé dans son orgueil
et tournai var a passé qui ne reviendra
plus je cite le quotidien libanais fait
également état de la possibilité que le
candidat puisse ne pas obtenir les 500
signatures nécessaires pour se présenter
le débat du système français des
parrainages à vieux serpent de mer de la
présidentielle et c'est à la une ce
matin du figaro qui reconnaît que la
polémique n'exclut pas une part de
dramatisation chez ceux qui peinent à
obtenir les précieux sésames mais que la
controverse et cette fois justifié
pourquoi me demanderez-vous damien par
louis bauer notamment parce que depuis
la réforme de 2016 qui rend public le
nom de chaque signataire de nombreux
élus locaux seraient soumis à des
pressions notamment de la part des
partis politiques à la une de la presse
également la suite du feuilleton novak
djokovic finalement libéré donc du
centre de détention où il était
contraint de rester depuis son arrivée
en australie le juge en charge de la
faire vous l'avez dit du visa du
champion de tennis a signifié que son
annulation n'était pas légal une
décision qui indispose la presse
australienne joe thornton on se moque de
nous vitupère de cormelles le
gouvernement australien peut néanmoins
encore posé des recours la sphère
djokovic d'avenir passionne décidément
les commentateurs novak djokovic est
devenu le bouc émissaire de la
frustration et de la peur de l'australie
face au coleader regrette de guardian
djokovic est l'une de ces supers stars
du sport pleurnicharde exagérément
convaincu d'être dans leur bon droit de
washington post lui est vent debout
contre la transformation des athlètes
vedette en 2010 ea phénomène qui
expliquerait selon le journal qu'une
partie d'entre eux perdent la tête et
imagine que parce qu'ils sont aussi ils
sont bons dans leur sport elles sont
aussi des experts dans des domaines
extrêmement éloignée
comme si l'on savait plus que le corps
médical sur la meilleure façon de lutter
contre le colis 19
merci beaucoup l année merci à vous
d'avoir choisi france 24 on se retrouve
dans un quart d'heure
[Musique]